Hello and welcome
to this lecture,
Microbiology,
Zoonotic Infections.
Zoonotic infections are
very important infections
and this is how actually
a lot of infections
throughout evolution
have came to us pretty
much as an accidental
interaction with animals.
Here are the
session objectives.
Basically, students
should be able after
this lecture to explain
how epidemiology,
virulence factors, host
defense mechanism, all
contribute to the
development of zoonotic
infection. You should be
able to differentiate between
key zoonotic
pathogens, apply common
microbiological testing
procedures to identify these
pathogens, and interpret
the actual results
from the lab to determine
an accurate diagnosis.
In this lecture, we
will be specifically
discussing these first
nine organisms, Yersinia,
Bacillus anthracis,
Borrelia, Leptosphera,
Rickettsia, Anaplasma,
Ehrlichia, Coxiella, French
cellula, and Brucellusis.
Now, of course, there's
other important zoonotic
pathogens like zoonotic
influenza, salmonella,
West Nile, SARS, and those
will be discussed in other
places. We'll be talking
about, of course, Lyme
disease in this particular
one, but we won't be
discussing influenza,
salmonella, West Nile, and
SARS specifically, because
they are covered in other
parts of the curriculum.
Let's first define the term
zoonotic infection. And
so zoonotic infections, any
infection that is acquired
from an animal where the
humans, we are not the
hosts, typically, it's just
an accidental, it happens.
And a lot of those actually
are not transmissible.
So once we acquire them
from the animal, whether
that is a vertebrate or an
invertebrate typically we
don't transmit them to
other hosts you know often
happens you require them
from animals that are pets or
or other options would be
like herd animals you know
because of occupational
hazards for example somebody
who works as a vet or a national
park or a slaughterhouse
per worker of course you
know children because
their immune system still
naive tend to be the most
affected group but you
know all groups can be
affected by this and some of
these can be very serious.
In the next couple
slides we discuss how we
get exposed to these
zoonotic infections
and discuss basically
the route of exposure.
One of the most common ways
of course is direct skin
***********. As we know
the skin is a pretty tight
organ and unless it's
poked very few organisms if
any can actually *********
the impact skin but if
it's you know if use a
mosquito tick anything that can
or scratch then you can
gain access so so of course
one of the things you
can get from animal bites
so the saliva of the animal
for example can transmit
the infectious agent to our
blood scratches uh urine
uh from you know animals
and and of course insect
bites, like in the case of
Rocky Mountain spot fever,
Lyme disease. These are
all examples of different
diseases that can be
transmitted by these modes.
In addition to direct
exposure, especially through
the skin, other ways are
ingestion and inhalation.
Inhalation, of course,
you have to have
aerosolized microbes, and
so the microbes have to
be able to do that. Anthrax
obviously can do that,
and that's called
inflammation anthrax. Urosinia
can do that too, and
that's pulmonary plague.
Q fever, the disease
caused by coxiella,
can also do that. Other ways by
which we can contract
is ingestion.
Anthrax is also can
transmit itself as a
gastrointestinal disease.
Cryptosporidium is that
way, and also leptospirosis.
Let's start by discussing
Yersinium. There's
two common pathogens in the
Yersinia genus, Yersinia
pestis, which the
cause of age, you know,
bubonic plague and Yersinia
endocolitica highlighted
there caused into
colitis or pseudo
appendicitis, more of a
gastrointestinal and thing.
Yersinia is a genus
that's gram negative,
facultative, anaerobic rot, rod
-shaped or cocovacillus
sometimes.
It's carinegative
and it doesn't have
the LPS and the
toxinia as part of it.
Yersinia typically tend to
be resistant especially to
cold and so you can really
enhance their isolation
and culture by growing them
at four degrees celsius.
Usually they're resistant
to phycocytosis. They have
what's called type 3 secretion
systems which are able
to like pump out a lot of
toxins that can get inside
their cells they can
suppress cytokine productions
and inflammation and that
way they can suppress the
immune system they also
have a capsule and and also
it's called plasminogen
activator protease which can
degrade our complement proteins
and prevent obstinization
which even further makes
it harder for our body
to phagocytize or the
phagocytes to recognize and
recognize and engulf
this pathogen.
Yersinia pestis which is
the cause of Asian or plague
can be acquired from of
course animals rodents cats
or dogs in both uh uh
salvatic uh environment which
basically means uh wooded
you know forests etc versus
your urban uh uh plague you
know it's one of them one
of the most notorious organisms
in the world of course
you know people throughout
history talked about
the pandemic plague that
killed 25 million in Europe.
There are still cases of
the plague throughout the
world, so it's not an extinct
disease, and we probably
get around 10 cases here in
the United States per year.
You can actually
spread it from person
to person if you end
up with pulmonary
plague, which is a
certain type of plague,
versus a more plastic bubonic.
You'll see Antarctica a
little bit more common.
100,000 people get
infected and typically from
drinking either contaminated
meat or drinking
contaminated milk or
water unpasteurized too.
The classic epidemics of
Yersinia usually cause what's
called bubonic plagues
and the term bubonic comes
from these lymph nodes
that gets inflamed in the
inguinal region and they
call them buboes so that's
where the name come from.
So typically, an infected
flea bites the person, you
end up getting fever, and
these bubos develop in the
inguinal region, and, you
know, on seven days later,
pretty high mortality
rate, especially without
treatment. And then there's
also the pneumonic version,
which is more of an
inhalation, a shorter
incubation period, two to three,
again, fever, pulmonary
symptoms, and an even
higher mortality, I would
say, 90%, even up to 100%.
So it's a pretty terrible
disease, for sure.
So it requires immediate
recognition and treatment.
Eucenia intocolitica,
like we talked about,
predominantly infect
kids and causes a,
you know, more of a
GI than anything else.
Average incubation for the
sick state, you end up with
****** diarrhea, fever,
abdominal pain, mostly involves
the last part, the
terminal alium of the small
intestine, and also some of
those nodes in the mesentery.
You can have complications like
septicemia, it's a
gram-negative organism.
abdominal abscesses,
even arthritis,
hepatitis, and
sometimes osteomyelitis,
so prompt treatment recognition
is very important
in these diseases.
Depending on the type and
condition, I assume it
can be isolated from
multiple different spots in
the body to blood, as you
can see the list here.
Typically cultured in a
medium that has cefaludine,
ergasin, and ovaleicin,
or CIN culture medium, or
specifically for its support
and growth of Yersinium. And
right here is a kind of
a link of an article that
about an actual laboratory
acquired infection that was
fatal from Yersinium. So
again, laboratory personnel
should handle these organisms
very, very carefully.
The next organism we're
going to talk about is
Bacillus anthracis. And
we didn't talk about or
will not discuss Bacillus
cereus, which is also
causes disease because
that's not a zoonotic.
only bacillus anthracis
is a zoonotic disease.
So all bacilli are gram
-positive rods, they're
obligate aerobes and they
are also spore-forming.
Bacillus anthracis
has a capsule and it's
obviously the ecological
agent of anthrax and
it can be involved
even in bio-terrorism.
Typically they're long,
they're very long,
all the bacilli are
very long rods and
sometimes are in chains.
Bacillus anthracis
specifically produces three
toxin, protective
antigen and edema factor.
And collectively, these two are
referred to sometimes
as edema toxin.
They act on cyclic AMP
and edemolate cyclase
resulting in movement
of water and massive
edema. And then there's
also lethal factor.
Lethal factor usually causes
macrophages to
die by apoptosis.
And, of course, all these
toxins end up inhibiting
our immune response, and
that's a terrible thing.
The capsule is made
out of this substance
called polydeglutamic
acid, and as always,
the capsule plays a major role
in pathogenesis and virulence.
Bacillus are soil
organisms, so you find them
in the soil, and that's
how livestock kind
of catches them,
especially if they are
vaccinated. And then, of
course, as typical with
all zoonoses, humans
are accidental hosts.
If you remember, some
of you may not remember,
but in 2001, there was
a purpose contamination
and sending of spores
of bacillus anthracis
through the United States
Postal Service, which
ended up actually
infecting few individuals.
and that was deemed the
bioterrorism type of incident.
Again with bacillus
you can acquire it
by inoculation into
the skin ingestion
resulting in a GI
or even inhalation.
The inhalation form of
anthrax is typically an
occupational hazard that used
to happen back in the day
when people assorted wool,
sheep wool, a lot of it,
and so as they did that,
you know, as the wool, as
the sheep roll into the
soil, they pick up the
spores of the bacillus, and
then as people are sorting
these wool in huge quantities,
they end up inhaling
the spores and developing
what's called wool sorters
disease, or inhalation
anthrax, which is a really
serious disease with a
very high mortality rate.
There's no known person
-to-person transmission of
anthrax, or, you know,
basically whoever gets it, it
sticks with that individual.
It's more animal to human.
And of course, we know
that the spores, and
we've talked about spores
before, that they are
highly resistant, makes
it in the environment,
and which makes it easier
to spread potentially.
From these three routes
of infection, inoculation,
ingestion, and
inhalation, you end up
with the three forms
of antics, cutaneous,
gastrointestinal, and pulmonary
or inhalation anthrax.
With cutaneous, of
course, there has to be a
crack in the skin and people
are handling something
that has the spores.
The spores go into the
blood, germinate, you know,
produce vegetative cells
and initially end up
what's called with a
painless papule and then
ulcers and becomes necrotic
and that's what's called
an ashgar. And you can
see that characteristic
look of it right here.
And because of the
black color, that's
where the word
anthrax come from.
Anthrax in Greek means black.
Gastrointestinal anthrax,
you know, can involve
multiple regions, you
know, resulting in sepsis,
edema, nausea, vomiting,
all that so an inhalation
infects the alveolar
macrophages and of course they
take the spores and sometimes
as the spore not the
spores sorry the cells
at this moment who reside
in these macrophages they
can produce like a latency
type of illness and
eventually usually the shock
at death within three days
with inhalation anthrax
if not treated and around
i would say almost 100%
mortality laboratory diagnosis
bacillus anthracis is
very visible on gram stain
as you can see here on the
right side i have one of
the like here's a rod shape
right there and this i
think probably a blood smear
long rods usually typically
in chains like you can see
right here gram positive of
course usually they prefer
a low co2 culture if you
want to go especially to
spores and if it's sporulating
you can actually see the
spores sometimes or the
endospores inside the cells
under the microscope you cannot
distinguish the different
types of bacilli they all
look the same bacillus
series anthracis look the
same but on blood dagger
bacillus anthracis is not
hemolytic and it also has a
very distinguished type of
colony so these colonies
right here are colonies of
bee and thraces which display
this what's called the
medusa head looks like a
medusa head you know the
greek um myth and so this kind
of um pretty diagnostic of
uh of bacilli bacillus and
thraces specifically um
all bacillus by the way
colonies look dry and strange
but you know this one is
obvious the strangest and of
course if you want to ever
highlight the capsule you
can use the the ink stain
And because of the
seriousness of the disease,
usually empiric treatment
is suspected right away with
sipoflotacin or doxy, and
then adding one or two
of the other antibiotics
to ensure full efficacy.
amoxicillin seems to be
very effective for cutaneous
anthrax and probably
the best prevention is
to vaccinate animals
and of course certain
individuals specifically
that are exposed or could be
exposed to anthrax like
military personnel or
occupational hazard handlers
or for veterinarians.
Next we're going to
talk about Borrelia.
Borrelia is a group
of gram-negative
spirochetes as you can
see from this fluorescent
microscopy right here
showing the squiggly
spirochetal bacterium.
There are two
main species that
cause diseases Borrelia
borgoferi and
Borrelia recurrentis.
They're transmitted by
the eggs of this tick
and the disease they
cause are Lyme disease
which is caused by
Borrelia borgoferi and then
relapsing fever,
which is caused by B.
recurrentis. They don't
think well with the gram
stain, and so that's why you
use something like Gimsa,
right, or even better, a
fluorescent microscope.
Again, zoonotic diseases,
so there are accidental
hostages. The bacteria is
transferred to us once the
tick borrows and bites,
and here's the exodus ticks
shown on the right side of
you and antibodies thankfully
can develop ticks of
course they take a while
after you get exposed to
any disease and but they can
be maintained and last for
years giving longer immunity
it is considered lung
disease considered the
leading vector-borne disease
in the united states with
95 of the cases as you can
see right here all in the
um northeast and then upper
midwest and so all the
way to maine and new york
and all the way down here
um virginia and then almost
michigan the reservoir
is the white fitted mouse
which is really a common
mouse and then the white
dld which is a very
common d2 is not a reservoir
but it's actually essential
for the life cycle of
the exodus tick and here
this figure shows the
reported cases the most recent
out of 2023 from the
Center for Disease Control.
And if you can see
there's obviously some
cases in other places
in the United States,
but they seem to
cluster in this region.
Lyme disease is sometimes
pretty hard to diagnose
if you have this classic
sign, which is the erythema,
migraines, rash, and that
usually will help with
the diagnosis, but that's
not always the case. It's
typically like the bull's
eye where the tick bites,
but sometimes that's, you
don't see that at all.
Of course, there's
macrosculoskeletal
manifestations, nervous
system, cardiovascular,
and of course, you
combine that with the lab.
Typically, in the lab,
we don't try to go borea,
burgafri, and usually
determine the diagnosis
from looking for IgM
antibodies, which is just a
recent infection. And
of course, if you're
looking for IgG, I need
to do an antibody titer
between different stages
to see if there's a jump,
otherwise this could be
from a prior infection.
And treatment for
this disease, like a
lot of them we've
talked about today, is
doxycycline and seems
to be effective.
And here's a summary for
you of Lyme disease and the
different clinical stages
by time, which starts out in
a month and several months
to weeks and then and then
down to a month and years where
you could have involvement
of the joints and what's
called Lyme arthritis.
Borrelia recurrentis causes
relapsing fever has the
name recurrent the actual
vector here is not a tick
it's the louse it's the
lice human lice typically
lice requires and spreads
more often whenever there's
crowded areas and whenever
there's like war zones
and so that's where it
allows a lot of lights to be
transmitted between people
and people can't have you
have proper sanitation they
can't shower etc most of
the current disease and
the burden of it occurs in
in places in africa in
countries like ethiopia ethereum
somalia and sudan and you
know one of the common
things among these countries
is a lot of civil war
too which exasperates this
issue So the organs in
Borrelia recurrentis seems to
display antigenic variation,
and the problem with
that is once you do that,
even if you acquire
antibodies immunity,
it doesn't matter,
then you end up
catching it again,
which is terrible.
Untreated, we have a
very high mortality, 70%.
So it's important to identify
and treat it properly.
Next we're going to talk
about is Liptospira or
Liptospirosis, also
spirochetes, but they have these
kind of hooked ends at the
end of them. As you can
see them right here, right
here, these tapered hooked
ends of this kind of
classic sign. They have a
flagella that goes all
across the spirochete like
this, so it kind of wraps
around it. They're obligate
aerobes and typically
require supplemental media.
Liptoprosis, people can
have quite the range. They
can have an almost
asymptomatic disease to a
very mild subclinical
infection to very mild flu
-like illness, but it can
also become very severe
in the systemic form
referred to as real disease.
2d gets in into mucous
membranes, cuts, anything
that basically breaks
those membranes. Early on
the infection, the organs
was localized, the blood,
even cerebrospinal fluid,
but eventually down.
Later it ends up in the
urine and then it's shed in
the body and of course
spread into the environment.
Like a lot of diseases,
some of these clinical
manifestations is really
the reaction of the immune
system to the pathogen,
resulting in tissue damage.
There's only about
100 to 200 infections
in the United States
of lip dysphorosis
per year, majority of
them in Hawaii, and
a lot of that has to
do with the weather,
and the organism
grows better in warmth
and likes water and
moisture and so on.
Dogs, livestock,
humans, all are
accidental hosts
of this disease.
the reservoir tends to be
rats predominantly and so
and they secrete the
organism in the urine because
the microbe grows in the
kidneys and end up just
colonizing and keep shedding
and shedding and shedding the
organism leptospira in the
in the water sources and
environment and that's how
other people catch it and
this is kind of a review
we talked about we talked
about the conical disease
happening through infection
of this or *********** of
the skin or conjunctivum
because of a break or
something like that you
have a brief incubation
period of one to
two weeks and then you
can develop flu-like
illness and remission
or progress to the more
severe form of systemic
cold wheel disease which
also involves you know
jaundice um and typically
you know people recover
and so thankfully
and there's no doesn't seem to
be any sequelae
after that either
but this burra can be
cultured but it's slow and
requires very specialized
culture like fletcher uh tween
80 with abumen supplementation
or what's called
emgh which stands for
ellinghausen mcclough johnson
harris media um dark
microscopy sorry dark field not
dark microscopy dark field
works very well because
liposbury are spirochetes
and it just shows these
squiggles very nicely but
you really have to do it from
the culture not directly
from a conical specimen
because they don't show
up very well um probably
antibody detection is the
best like eclatination fast
quicker instead of waiting
for the culture and so on
again treatment is penicillin
iv or doxy and works
very well and if you need
prophylaxis it's also doxy
next organism we're
going to discuss is
rickettsia rickettsia
rickettsia in general are
obligate intercellular gram
negative rods they don't
show up well in the gram
stain so the gram negativity
is redetermined by microscopy
rickettsia rickettsia
is the cause evasion of
rocky mountain spotted
fever and but you could
stain it with specialized
stains you know like gimsa
or the germanus stain uh
you can see right here inside
uh well i probably think
this is a monocyte so i'm
going inside of it this
red like uh ratchet small
lab organisms typically
transmitted by arthropods
specifically the
dermocentrum or towards
Roberto as the dark
tick organs tend to
be the reservoirs and
transmission or trans
-ovarian transmission
in the tick section
allows the tick to be both
the host and the vector
so you can go very nicely
inside the tick this is
the distribution of rocky
mountain spotted fever
in the united states and
as you can see here the
majority of the cases happen
in this area the states
of arkansas missouri
north carolina tennessee
and virginia where they
share the most burden of
the cases now of course
you can get in other places
too including arizona
you can see adheres
to the torrent of the
union uh the landing
of our blood vessels to
the outer membrane protein
a or omp outer membrane
protein which is of course
a very important evidence
factor that allows it
to stick to our cells uh
this results in um vascular
leakage hypotenia and
hypopropenia because designed
to settle the pathogens
you pretty much have to
kill the cell of the urine
so this is why the t-side
of toxic cells are vital
and we're getting rid of
this organ the tick bites
dog tick as we talked about
and i end up with a rash
on the neck you see right
here on the right side
and usually three days
after the the doc take
bites and after seven
days or if you have high
fever headache plays lots
of fluid symptoms and
insecurity can become
worse for example if the
rash turns to a particular
that tells us it's
not a good diagnosis
usually a poor prognosis
It could be pre-enhanced
disease with almost 10 to
25% fatality rate, especially
if it's not treated.
And a lot of these are
related to the endotoxin
that's made by this
gram-negative organism.
How to diagnose Rocky Mountain
Spons here back in the
day, the real felix test
was used, which is basically
an I-cognition test. It's
a cheap one. It's quick.
If you're in a setting
which don't have a lot
of access to high
-end testing, it works
fine. But compared to
other tests, it's not a
sensitive or a specific,
a better, more expensive
one is the
microamilofluorescent assay.
The treatment, again, is
toxic and it is effective.
Next, we can talk about
other species of rickettsia,
rickettsia provoziki.
And rickettsia provoziki,
unlike rickettsia, which
causes rickettsia, which is
a very different organism
causes epidemic typhus.
It usually is transmitted
by the human mouse. you can
see the mouse on the on
the side here on the right
side okay and it's mainly
confined and spread into
central and south america
after and typically because
of the labs again is uh
crowded conditions and a poor
sanitation thing very
important is better disease
um and also there is
a is a disease that
can develop or you can
think of it as a cup
is sequelae or complication
but happens uh kind of
a native form after the
epidemic typhus and recover
you can get you could this
disease called bullseiser
disease which is kind
of a remission and it
can happen after first
infections and the brain seems
to be a little bit more
common on military personnel
that's triggered by, of
course, stress or any
immunosuppression.
Next, we're going
to talk about two
organisms at the same
time because they're
very similar,
anaplasma and lithium.
They're both into a settler
and they pretty much
target our phycocytes
anaplasma predominantly
targets or grows inside
polymorphor nuclear
cells or granulocytes
neutrophils mainly and
alicia predominantly
it tries to grow inside
monocytes both organisms
prevent the phycosome from
binding into the lysosome
so they prevent the
and they end up
just sitting inside
the fibrosis or
inside our phycosides.
They are considered
ground-negative,
but they don't seem
to have the glycan
or LPS, so they're
very typical.
And so, of course, they will
not stain by the gravestone.
You and your GIMSA are
right, and they do...
If you perform cirrhosis,
there's a lot of cross
-reaction between the both
of them and other organisms.
Typically, they're transmitted
by ticks, Lichia is
transmitted by what's called
the lone star tick, and
the host is the white-tailed
deer, while ionoplasma
is transmitted by exodus
tick, which we talked
about today, and usually
the hosts are small organs.
it's an emerging disease
that popped up in 1986
in the United States
again the long star tick
and white tailed in the
reservoir and once they
write 22 weeks you
develop basically full
accident and you can end
up with a late onset rash
which is also developed
and people that are
immunocompromised, they
can end up with sepsis.
Most people require
hospitalization with a
2 to 3 percent mortality,
although not high.
There is a pretty
serious mortality burden.
And right here on the
right side, you can see the
monocytes with that
kidney-been-shaped nuclei.
And here is the
organism here growing
inside the phagazole,
inside the monocytes.
anaplasmos is called by
anaplasma phagocyte two
films you can see the
phytocyte which is phycocyte
again these guys really
like to target uh
granulocytes uh probably
work for nuclear cells
usually the tick is the
exodus tick and then
the bite comes from that
five to ten days again
So the reservoir and the eye
fever, malaise, thombostata,
the appropriate, but they
should look up in hand,
and peripheral neuropathy is a
normal sequence
of this disease.
And then right here on
the right side, we can
see an anaplasma going
inside the polymorphonuclear
cell in neutrophil.
And here's the
organ going right there
inside that fibrozone.
Well, a liquean and a
plasma are typically
can be seen with
the Gimsa stain.
Again, gram stain is not
effective with those.
They don't really
have peptoglycan and
they're intracetal, so
they're very hard to see.
Nucleic acid amplification
and serology might be the
best choices, but remember,
with serology, there's a
lot of cross-reactivity with
rachymonic spotted fever,
acute fever, Lyme, brucellosis.
So it's really not very
conclusive. um so maybe a
nucleic acid amplification
might be the best choice
here and treatment is again
doxy and it is effective
let's talk about coxiella
bernetti coxiella bernetti
is defined as a gram negative
organism it weakly grams
things it's not very reliable
uh to use and you can't
see it very properly it's
caused a division of q fever
and the word q means query
and i think it was named
after the fact that people
can figure out what this
fever was caused for so query
means because they're looking
for it um coxiella usually
delays apoptosis in cells
and it's an intercellular
pathogen so it likes to
keep the host cell alive so
it can grow inside of it
uh most of of the reservoir
is an animal herd animals
like sheep goats and cattle
The source comes from mostly
the patient of the organism,
feces of ticks and
like placentities,
and feces of all the
infected animals.
And then individuals were
inherited accidentally.
So most of the
infections are happening
because of occupational
hazards, veterinarians,
fruit, hamburgers,
ranchers, farms, et cetera.
with Coxie 11 patients
start with mild symptoms and
then of course you get an
abrupt high-grade fever and
high-skill fever and
fatigue I think my own being
severe C quality occurs
in five percent of cases
approximately with hepatitis
pneumonia and non-fever
potentially with those cases
it can look like tuberculosis
and it can become chronic
again with like subacute
endocarditis especially if
there is a immune suppressed
situation or some pathology
in the heart valves
most commonly diagnosed
coxial disease by swallogy
typically using monophilicent
antibody which works
pretty good treatment doxy
uh at least for two weeks
and there's a chronic form
of of chemotherapy and
then you have hydroxy
chloroquine that seems to be
affected there's a vaccine
which is kind of an older
inactivated wholesale
vaccine uh typically used for
like infected animals uh
and then i'm sorry infected
animals to prevent the
spread animal workers and
people that are exposed to
animals to prevent it but
Next we're going to
talk about is the genus
franciscelledaline is focusing
on franciscelledalinesis.
It's a aerobic gram-negative.
You can see it right
here in the gram-stained
below, very faintly
staining the cocovis.
It's considered an
inter-cellular organism.
It's a fastidious organ.
It requires a
system, an additive
to the growth of the growth.
Not ideal to grow this in
culture because it's clean
and biohazardous and you
can infect yourself of it.
It's capsuline,
it's transmitted by
ticks and deer flies
and or even exposure
to rabbits if you
have an open wound.
right here shows the
kind of the cases in the
united states out of 2023
and we can see most of the
cases are clustered
in the arkansas area
region so
as we just discussed
most of the cases
are actually in
oklahoma arkansas and
as you can see on
the previous slide.
Main means for the disease
tolenia, which is caused
by Prensis of Prensis.
There's glandular fever,
there's rabbit fever, because
it can be acquired from
secretions of
rabbits or infected
rabbits, tick fever, all of
them hangers, ticks, and
it can be spread by exodus
in my center and in the
embryo Well, the most
common manifestation you
see right here, which is
these also local endover
regions of papyrus become
necrotic, endopathy and
bacturinium, you can
also have the ocular
endotrophorations, mnemonic,
typhoidal, which
is more general,
oropharyngeal, and
intestinal so this is
an organism that is
you know on the top
list of the
bioterroristic agents too
again very biohazardous
organism and i think that the
main reason for that is
the low infectious dose
required to acquire to anemia
which is usually below 10.
10 individual organisms so
that's that's probably why
it's so hazardous so even
a small amount of only can
cause infection typically
go in buffer charcoal yeast
extract and that has
cysteine as supplement to it
you see why is also the same
medium used for going regional
typically surrounding
with antibody diaries
is used for diagnosis
treatment is gentilizing
It seems to be
effective, but you can't
tolerate it, you can
also use doxy or several.
Sometimes very
quick identification
of the tick can
prevent infection,
but you have to know
it's there because
a lot of times we
don't even feel
the ticks, we just
have to see them.
Let's discuss
Prasolmosis, which has
four different common
species. it's a
versella abortus, a
versella menatensis,
a versella canis,
and a versella sois.
And even those are
named after the organism
that was environment.
So for abortus, it's
cattle, menatensis,
it's goats, canis,
canines or dogs, and
sois, always menis, pigs.
Usually causes proselysis or
what's called albumin fever.
It's a non-mortile,
doesn't have a
capsule or a gram
-negative cocoacilis.
It's aerobic.
It doesn't do any fermentation.
It's also a slow-growing.
It predominantly packs
out the particular
decennial cells and
resides inside the
cells because it's an
intraceptic pathogen.
So again, it sits in the
spring, river, kidney, warmer,
wind nodes. That's the big
thing, that's the locations.
Bricellosis is endemic
in many places in the
world. This is kind of
what's called a heat map,
from the center of risk
control, showing the
localization of
bricellosis in the world.
Latin America,
Africa, North the
East, et cetera.
Our names for
diseases, Malta fever,
there's many different
names for decisions usually
there's 80 140 cases in
united states annually
again transmitted by
cattle pigs and animals and
usually the route is their
products unpasteurized a
lot of this is not pasteurized
products so unprocessed
well and very rarely
you can acquire from
initially inhalation but
this is the predominant route
typically diagnosis
of brucella happens by
checking for a fold for
four fold rise and antibody
titer which is just
a new infection or an
acute infection and
also you're cultured on
blood dagger but you
gotta read at least two
weeks before because the
slug work to make sure
the cell also seems to have
an affinity for the sugar
called uh a sugar that's
found in specifically in
high concentration in some
of our organs like breasts
uterus placenta and the epidemis
uh typically some things
occur one please after
exposure you know malaise
chills sweats looks a lot
like even initially kind of
tuberculosis it's also a
just like during courses um
the fever can come and go
hence the name sometimes
given to this disease which
is um of course without
treatment the infection always
progresses into a chronic
infection with several a
month and it can also involve
the bone and multiple organs
and it really makes the
person that i'm able to it's
a pretty hard i mean the
recovery eventually that
is a very hard recovery
treatment is really toxic
combined with refampin for
women and children it's
pregnant when less than eight
years old um children is
eight years old it's trimester
from supplements also
instead of doxin you should
treat a beast over six weeks
again because that conicity
and the slow metabolism
of the organism uh best
prevention is vaccination
with animals there's a live a
10-minute vaccine for that
and definitely avoiding as
we talked about the
unpasteurized and improperly
processed baby products and
you never have to worry about
proselytosis this is a
sample case for you guys to
practice um the speaker
presents a 35 year old male
to a family physician
with history of joint pain
you know you recall having
a great fever malaise
works as a landscaper
on the eastern island
and uh he had one question
he had a rash and here's a
picture of it and then you
can try to answer those
questions what's the
likelihood how does the disease
evolve correctly based on
the you can answer this based
on the lecture you understand
this is a real pediatric
case of for your own
information here's the link of
it there's no general
medicine for your own perusal
in summary there's
a really wide
variety of zoonotic infections
a lot of them are caused by
blood-borne pathogens and
at some point a lot of the
infections that we even
couldn't have that we don't
consider zoonotic like
tuberculosis influenza at
one point they were all
zoonotic and then got
transmitted those accidents from
animals and over time they
evolved and became human
diseases that should be able
to fall in that category
again many people are
transmitted by zoonotic affected
by insects out of bonds
and animal reservoirs
and a lot you know skin
issues seem to be common where
it works and access out
blood through this game.